good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson here people see the federal
government seems big maybe bigger than
ever well it actually is the largest
employer in the world the federal
government nothing else comes close not
Google not Amazon not the Communist
Party of China nothing how many people
work for the United States government
let's put it this way there are more
than a hundred countries around the
world whose total populations that is
every man woman and child are smaller
than our federal Workforce entire
countries many of them
the US government in other words is
astoundingly large World historically
big scale without Preston truly
gargantuan
so what do all those people who work
there do every day maybe wondering that
what's a good question actually nobody's
really sure including many of the
employees themselves fundamentally the
federal government is a mystery like the
universe it goes on forever it makes you
feel small thinking about it which is
probably the point the good news is
every once in a while our government
does something you can actually
understand that happened recently when
Joe Biden signed a 750 billion dollar
piece of legislation called the
inflation reduction Act what does the
inflation reduction act do come on what
are you slow the answer is right there
in the name the inflation reduction Act
is an act that reduces inflation it's an
inflation reducing Act
and that's welcome news because
inflation is indeed a problem in fact
voters say it's the problem they worry
about most so Congress has decided to
reduce it that's how things work in
Washington you identify a crisis and
then you pass a law making it illegal
crisis solved it's simple getting too
hot for you this summer no problem just
have Congress write a law Banning high
temperatures it's effectively our
climate change policy and as we know it
works the science on that has been
settled don't deny it now Congress has
decided to bring that very same approach
to inflation just command it to go down
you can imagine how terrified inflation
will be when it discovers it's being
reduced by our all-powerful Congress
wait it'll say in horror you passed an
inflation reduction act okay fine I
Surrender gas is now a dollar fifty a
gallon hamburger is two bucks a pound
sorry for the high prices
that's the promise of this act anyway
but in real life a lot of people are
still wondering how is this going to
work
Hillary Vaughn from Fox was wondering
that so yesterday she caught up with
Senator Joe manchin of West Virginia
Mansion is the man the single man whose
vote made this bill possible
is the inflation reduction act really
going to reduce inflation she asked
here's how Joe manchin responded
when it comes to inflation is it
misleading to call this the inflation
production act for Americans when it's
not going to make their grocery bill
cheaper it's not going to make everyday
Goods cheaper for them why would it why
would it well immediately it's not but
we never seen anything happen
immediately like today it's turned the
switch on and off
so is Hillary Vaughn pointed out
correctly the law won't immediately make
anything cheaper to buy in other words
it will not reduce inflation
but Joe manchin didn't deny this he
didn't seem bothered by it in fact his
response was why would it
well let's see because you told us it
would you dishonest little creep and
then you printed another 750 billion
dollars of fake money which is exactly
the Habit that caused historic inflation
in the first place all this fake money
printing
so what's the upside of this bill
exactly Joe manchin didn't say
Congressman Jamie Raskin of Maryland
couldn't explain it either watch this
I note that those who have been blaming
President Biden for the inflation going
up are now giving President Biden all
the credit for inflation going down so
we're moving things in the right
direction already and what parts of the
bill do you think we'll we'll quickly
work on that specifically
next question
I'm Jamie Raskin I'll say anything
what parts of the inflation reduction
act will actually reduce inflation next
question says we're asking he actually
said that out loud as you just saw in
other words you've caught me lying and I
don't even care go away peasant
so as it turns out we hate to break this
to you the inflation reduction act may
be a classic example of misinformation
imagine buying a bottle labeled shampoo
and finding out the hard way it was
actually drain cleaner it's like that
so if there's one thing we can learn
from the so-called inflation reduction
act it's that in Washington words no
longer have any meaning at all
the empires officially entered its
post-modern phase where there's no
connection whatsoever between the sounds
that emerge from the mouths of our
leaders and observable physical reality
Congress might as well have called this
the Eternal happiness Act and why not
that'll probably be the name of the next
bill Joe Biden signs and we hope so
because we are long overdue for
Washington to ban sadness they ought to
get on that
not this bill
was even thought about by Joe Biden not
that he even noticed this bill Biden
doesn't get too caught up in the meaning
of words these days Biden is
definitively post-literate at this point
here's the scene as he signed his most
recent legislative Triumph
okay
Leo it's Nella
foreign
here we go
I might as well put a sign on his desk
saying this guy has no idea what he's
doing right now because he didn't and it
couldn't have been more obvious the
thousand yard stare was the giveaway
there were Doughboys in Verdun who
looked less shell-shocked than Biden
just did but the question I mean what
was in the bill
let's see you'll be happy to know that
this bill the inflation reduction act
includes three billion dollars for the
US Postal Service to buy new electric
mail trucks so why would your mailman
need an electric mail truck no one has
ever explained that but your mailman is
getting one and China is getting even
richer from the electric mail truck
batteries which it makes
so there's that
then there's another three billion
dollars allocated to block grants for
something called environmental justice
that'll be overseen by the EPA which
used to look after the environment but
now it's in the Justice business
environmental justice gets about 60
billion dollars in this new legislation
which is great if you're in the
environmental justice business but it
leaves the rest of us wondering what is
environmental justice actually
well according to the bill it means that
we are quoting here facilitating
engagement of disadvantaged communities
in state and federal advisory groups
workshops rule makings and other public
processes
okay that sounds confusing but also
expensive
in all the EPA alone gets more than 40
billion dollars in this bill including
more than 30 billion for so-called
disadvantaged communities what are those
well they're not really defined people
who vote for Joe Biden
so what it really means is the EPA is
going to spread more identity politics
and race hate are you sick of that yet
the Biden White House is not sick of it
they're all in for context to show you
just how all in they are on that the
total annual budget of the EPA currently
stands at about 10 billion dollars so
this is a lot of money flowing to equity
in the disadvantaged
and of course everything hangs on
definition so who gets to Define what
disadvantages a disadvantaged community
well that would be the epa's
administering a guy called Michael Regan
this is a guy who's in his late 40s who
has never had an actual job in his life
never worked for real business of any
kind
but he does have priorities and to give
you some sense of what they are we'll
tell you what he told The Daily Show
this year and we're quoting everything I
do at EPA is through the lens of
environmental justice Contracting
procurement air quality water quality
Land Management starts with are we
protecting the least Among Us those who
have lacked political representation and
those who have not been at the table for
decades end quote
so really this is about spreading race
hate as virtually everything they do is
they call it Equity it's not about
protecting the environment
and if you're wondering how the
environment's doing take a very close
look is anyone monitoring the chemicals
in our water no
we're busy conducting workshops for
billions of dollars with disadvantaged
communities right
so
that may not be helping the environment
but it's definitely not reducing
inflation inflation reduction is not the
same as protecting people who lack
political representation that's of
course Joe Biden's base the 81 million
who voted for him that's what this bill
is really about rewarding his voters
that would include virtually every
bureaucrat in Washington they do very
well in this bill of course as long as
they promise to spend it on Equity
however they want to Define that there's
25 million dollars for the government
accountability office to determine quote
whether the economic social and
environmental impacts or the funds
described in this paragraph are
Equitable the bill also calls for 10
million to be spent on Equity
commissions within the Department of
Agriculture to combat racism in other
words to commit racism really not since
the German government 80 years ago has
any government ever paid closer
attention to people's genetics that's
true and yet no one notices it for some
reason what we do
there's more than two billion dollars
for the general Services Administration
something called the federal permitting
Improvement steering Council that gets
350 million the Bureau of Indian Affairs
gets 220 million the office native
Hawaiian relations gets 23 million and
it's not just bureaucrats who are
getting paid they're billions of dollars
in new tax credits who do those go to
Joe Biden's donors of course not to you
are you in private Equity no no you're
not so you don't get anything Biden
described these credits yesterday
the inflation reduction act invest
369 billion dollars to take the most
aggressive action ever ever ever ever in
confronting the climate crisis and
strengthening our economic our energy
security
it's going to offer Working Families
thousands of dollars in savings by
providing them rebates to buy new and
efficient appliances weatherize their
homes get tax credit for purchasing heat
pumps and rooftop solar electric stoves
ovens
so you you watch that and you realize
maybe they are going to run him again
because he doesn't actually exist he is
merely a conduit through which they
change America there's no idea what he's
saying he reads the script he seems kind
of non-threatening and out of it that
may seem embarrassing to you a problem
to you you wonder what does his wife
think of all this it's so demeaning and
degrading it's cruel to do this to a guy
feed him full of drugs in him read
someone else's script
but if you're trying to change the
country really fast this is very useful
to you so of course they're going to run
them again
so again to the bill a non-profit called
rewiring America which supports this
bill decided to figure out how much
money Americans are eligible to receive
from the inflation reduction act based
on zip code household income tax filing
status so according to rewiring in
America a married couple with one child
in San Francisco earning the median
household income there of a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars would be
eligible for nearly twelve thousand
dollars in tax credits but according to
that same group that same family of
three making the median income in
Youngstown Ohio for example would be
eligible for just 81 in tax credits oh
that's weird so the middle class gets
shafted while people making 120 Grand in
San Francisco make out
okay
so most Americans who are making middle
class wages should be eligible for more
savings only if they're willing to go
out and spend thousands of dollars on
things like a new heat pump water heater
an electric stove or a heat pump clothes
dryer right none of which work very well
but the bigger issue is that all these
tax credits for Joe Biden's base are
going to increase inflation this is the
same thing that happened to college
tuition when the government subsidized
it it got much more expensive
perfect and that's already started as
the Washington examiner has reported
electric vehicle manufacturers are now
raising the price of their cars now the
so-called inflation reduction act
includes a 700 7 500 tax credit for
electric vehicles quote ahead of the
inflation reduction act saying the tax
credit of up to 7 500 bucks for purchase
of new electric and hybrid vehicles Ford
and GM announced price increases at
similar rates you following this
so the government
pays you back your own money to buy a
product and then the manufacturer of the
product raises the cost of that same
product by the same amount oh so it's a
subsidy for them not savings for you
last week Ford announced price hikes
between six thousand eight thousand five
hundred for most of its lineup of its
F-150 Lightning Electric Vehicles while
General Motors upped its electric Hummer
costs by sixty two hundred fifty dollars
last month
so what is that
they don't want to answer the question
because the only potentially
deflationary aspect of this bill is the
tax increase which is of course probably
not a good idea when you're in a
recession
but our government is not willing to cut
spending and stop printing money so
instead their solution is to take money
from you this is this is classic right
so you print all the money you want
because you hold the reserve currency
and then when inflation goes up you just
try and pull it out of the system
through taxation that's modern monetary
Theory look it up according to the
Congressional budget office this act
will cost the middle class 20 billion
dollars a year in new taxes The Joint
Committee on taxation is concluded that
Under The Spill 61 percent of taxpayers
make between 40 and 50 Grand will see a
tax increase 91 percent of Americans
make it between 75 and 100 will see
their taxes go up and 97 percent of
Americans make between 100 and 200 we'll
see their taxes go up
so if you're making 100 Grand in
Arlington Virginia are you rich Oh no
you're barely scraping by
so it turns out
that Biden was lying just yesterday he
told us that no one making under 400 000
a year will see their taxes go up watch
and I'm keeping my campaign commitment
no one let me emphasize no one earning
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year will pay a penny more in federal
taxes
folks
yeah not a penny more I mean again you
can't blame the guy he's just a
mannequin
but whoever wrote that knew he was lying
there is one group of Americans who will
not pay more under that bill that's
Biden's donors the richest people in the
country
thanks to the Democratic party's hedge
fund support and they have a lot of that
the private Equity world the final
revision of this bill keeps the carried
interest loophole in our tax code
that means that people who work in
finance many parts of Finance are able
to
report their income as interest and pay
half the taxes that you do no one can
defend this policy
it is indefensible even people who
benefit from it will not defend it
they're embarrassed of it they take
advantage of it of course but it's a
scam and everybody knows it and yet it
remains in our tax code because they
paid off the Democratic senator from
Arizona and a bunch of others
so just in case the message wasn't clear
the bill gives the IRS another 80
billion dollars to hire 87 000 new
Auditors so what do those new Auditors
those armed Auditors of the IRS have to
do with a tax code this unfair well the
truth is if you have a tax code this
unfair and it keeps getting more unfair
every year you have to hire armed goons
to make people obey because they won't
otherwise
87 000 new armed IRS agents how many is
that well for perspective the IRS
currently has about 78 000.
total
so this bill will make the IRS larger
than the army of the nation of Italy
also the nation of the Philippines also
the UK
what
thanks Joe manchin so what are those
agents going to be doing we're not sure
but we do have an IRS training video for
you watch
in addition to be an accountants were
also Law Enforcement Officers which is
very interesting because a lot of the
special agents that work for the IRS
they don't come from a law enforcement
background we get to do the same things
like all the other law enforcement
officers do things happen we have to be
able to respond so we have to be ready
so we teach our agents too far a firearm
to be able to shoot we teach them
defensive tactics and methods of
Defending themselves and protecting
others as well so they go through that
entire process so that not only can they
analyze records but they also have that
law enforcement component
so in an actual democracy IRS agents
should be taught to be polite
but under Joe Biden IRS agents are
taught quote to shoot
how should I not war on the population
of the country
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight